[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sport sur tv 78 à l'émission à ne pas
manquer si vous êtes un passionné de
sport local c'est parti pour le sommaire
football nous parlerons de la coupe de
france coup de projecteur sur les
résultats des clubs heavy noah et
notamment de la défaite du petit poucet
bréval longue le club des cinq a perdu
face à vincennes un club de r un
reportage handball les féminines de
montigny le bretonneux jouer ce week-end
contre le club d'ici à paris et lésigny
montel ont remporté leur troisième
victoire de la saison zoom dans ce
magazine baseball nous avons posé notre
caméra du côté du stade jean maréchal de
montigny le bretonneux pour rencontrer
les cougars focus notamment sur les
sections jeunes et l'équipe senior qui
fait partie des meilleures équipes de
france l'actualité sportive c'est
maintenant sur tv 78
[Musique]
mais avant de développer ces titres on
va parler à box et d'une potentielle
mauvaise nouvelle pour l'illinois tony
hawk à sa médaille d'or olympique gagne
en 2016 à rio pourrait lui être retirée
c'est ce que laisserait croire une
enquête indépendante le professeur de
droit canadien richard mclaren à qui
l'on doit notamment ses investigations
sur le dopage russes slaves lé jeudi
dernier des potentiels faits de
corruption dans la boxe olympique sept à
dix combats de rio-2016 ferait l'objet
de sérieux soupçons de manipulation des
juges la france l ouzbékistan serait
particulièrement avantagé parmi ces
combats à la finale remportée par tony
hawk à aux points contre l'anglais john
joyce dans le viseur le français karim
bouzidi ancien directeur exécutif de
l'association internationale de boxe
amateur limogé trois jours avant la fin
des jeux olympiques de 2016 trente six
juges et arbitres avaient été par
ailleurs écarté quelques mois après
l'échéance les faits s'ils sont avérés
pourrait avoir de fortes répercussions
et menacer la médaille d'or du boxeur
originaire de chanteloup les vignes de
son côté à joyce le boxeur de la finale
a déjà avait clamé à sa médaille d'or on
va maintenant parler de là coupe de
france de football le petit poucet à
bréval longue qui évolue en d5 de
district s'est finalement incliné face à
vincennes qui évolue cette division au
dessus le score 2 à 0 les détails avec
bixente mais rien sorti steban un match
pour l'histoire petit poucet de la coupe
de france de football édition 2021 2022
le club de bréval longue qui évolue en
dernière division départementale jouer
son destin face aux vins c'est loin
c'est aux sept divisions plus haut c'est
un vrai honneur pour pour le club titré
le petit club connaît le la petite ville
et aujourd'hui on se retrouve on est là
au saint graal au quatrième tour et
c'est une vraie fierté pour nous malgré
l'écart sur le papier entre les deux
équipes préval a voulu jouer sa chance
jusqu'au bout là on doit tout donner et
mon équipe à la pas le niveau d'un petit
poucet donc je pense que il ya moyen de
faire de grandes choses je la gagne ça
c'est des joueurs ont deux bras des gens
comme nous il faut y aller c'est la
gagne au bout il a craqué contrefaçon
qui étaient garés santé aujourd'hui pour
nous ce qui est important c'est pas
prendre de but dans le premier quart
d'heure faut qu'on se donne les moyens
d'y croire on sait que ça va être
difficile tenir le plus longtemps
possible dans un stade où le public
était présent pour pousser les joueurs à
l'exploit on sent vraiment un engouement
autour de cet événement là on a bataillé
pour arriver jusqu'ici dominée en trois
matches et c'est vrai que là aujourd'hui
on sent que tout le club est d'ailleurs
à nous tous nos villages même on peut
dire donc on espère faire honneur aux
supporters qui vont venir nous voir
c'est historique pour valent donc
franchement c'est bien on est content de
représenter les couleurs de ce club coke
et je serai fier de mes joueurs s'ils
donnent tout porté par la foule et les
maillots blancs de la coupe de france
bréval a su contenir les attaques 20
seynoise jusqu'à la toute fin de la
première période
un but juste avant la pause qui
n'atténuera pas les espoirs breva loi
mais réduit à dix en fin de match ils
vont encaisser un second but dans les
dernières minutes une défaite donc 2 à 0
qui sonne presque comme une victoire
tant les sept divisions d'écart ne se
sont pas remarqué sur le terrain
on va continuer à parler de la coupe de
france et des autres résultats sportifs
du week end en lésiné avec bixente
mérian santisteva qui nous a rejoint sur
ce plateau bonsoir bixente on sent
michael alors en football bréval on ya
perdu gens pouvaient s'y attend mais
quand les types d autre club yvelinois
dans cette coupe de france rassuré nous
il y en aura au 5e tour bien vous
souvenez michael il y a deux semaines on
avait passé le troisième tour avec un
bilan tout juste passable de dix clubs
sur 20 la moyenne donc la moyenne et
cette semaine on est au dessus michael
avec sept clubs sur 12 retiendra
notamment la démonstration de chatou 8,0
à quincy voisins autre victoire à
l'extérieur conflans sur le terrain de
pontault combault 4 0 pour son entrée
dans la compétition versailles l'a
également emporté 3 0 face à brétigny
une nationale 3 donc si tu es une
division seulement dé versailles qui
sont eux en nationale 2 la déception
c'est bien entendu le club de houille
défait contre 5 michel 91 un club
largement en dessous des hobbies loi sur
le papier 1 0 donc et ce week-end
c'était aussi une histoire de tirs au
but cinq équipes évinoise sont arrivés
coude à coude avec leurs adversaires au
bout du temps réglementaire et 3
longtemps porté je pense à poissy contre
gretz tournan trappe face au paris
université club et chambre aussi contre
villeneuve ablon est d'ailleurs
chambourcy et notre nouveau petit poucet
yvelinois puisqu'ils sont les seuls
pensionnaires du district restant
puisque ce n'est pas passé pour
voisins-le-bretonneux plaisir et donc
bréval l'onu a souhaité un meilleur
résultat pour chambre sied plutôt que
pour bréval longue alors ça joue un
basket également ce week-end avec une
démonstration du côté de trappes 78 à 39
michael moi je n'appelle même plus à une
démonstration 78 39 c'est au mieux une
balade matinale du dimanche à la rosée
du matin on peut dire sans rougir qu'il
y avait plusieurs classes d'écart ce
samedi sur le parquet du gymnase paul
mallet une victoire qui permet donc aux
trappistes de poursuivre leur bon début
de saison trois matches et trois
victoires donc pour une place en haut du
classement à égalité avec levallois en
basket féminin à victoire aussi pour
l'entente le chesnay versailles oui en
nationale 2 féminine le chesnay
versailles s'est imposé à la maison
contre landerneau club breton score
final 58 à 46 ce résultat permet au club
de continuer son sans faute du début de
saison de la même manière que trappe
chez les garçons elle enchaîne une
troisième victoire de suite et pointent
en tête de leur division du rugby avec
le championnat de fédérale 3 oui la
fédérale 3 avec un derby michael entre
les deux pensionnaires du département
maisons laffitte et oui et le ml sgpc
qui s'imposent largement 51 à 10 6
essais à 2 synonyme aussi de bonus
offensif le deuxième en deux matches
pour le club qui prend ainsi seul les
commandes du championnat où ils
n'avancent pas en revanche et concède sa
deuxième défaite en deux journées à
noter que comme neuf équipes sont en
lice dans la division le rc versailles
étaient dispensées de matches pour ce
week-end
maintenant michael si je vous dis
dragonboat ça vous fait penser à quoi
alors j'imagine des bateaux j'imagine
l'asie ça vous y êtes presque vous
n'êtes pas loin pour comprendre on va
prendre la direction de mantes la jolie
pour cette compétition insolite les
championnats de france de dragonboat
était organisée ce week-end sur le stade
nautique international didier simon
c'est donc un sport collectif qui
consiste à pagayer en rythme au son des
tambours pour être en parfaite
synchronisation sur l'eau avec un
objectif en tête aller le plus vite
possible et le plus loin au total 250
sportifs étaient présents sur le site on
écoute l'un des organisateurs lionel
fraysse
c'était un championnat de france très
attendu c'était le champion de france
n'a pas eu de compétition de brian bolt
depuis deux ans et dernière fois c'était
le championnat français saint jean de
losne en 2019 donc c'était très attendu
déjà de se retrouver et effectivement
devoir sportivement ou en été sur le
territoire
on a donc le club de mantes-la-jolie
comme organisateur qui le majeur qui a
remporté
une grande grande majorité des courses
here enfin on termine notre tour
d'horizon des résultats pas sur un
résultat mais une autre note encore plus
insolite et vous me direz michael quoi
de plus insolites que le dragon de brut
cc nous surprendre bixente michael vous
savez que le paris saint germain a perdu
2-0 ce week-end à rennes déjà ça c'est
une nouvelle surprenante et bien encore
plus surprenant certains chanceux ont pu
croiser clients mba paix ou encore
achraf hakimi à l'intermarché de trappes
il semblerait qu'il soit soit arrêté
faire quelques petites emplettes avant
leur match en terre bretonne bon c'est
pas trop ce qui leur a pris michael
peut-être un petit coup de fatigue au
milieu des rayons oui ou peut-être
qu'ils ont pris les renseignements pour
pour peut-être rejoindre le strap on ne
sait pas pour information à qui elle
aime ma paix et libre à partir du mois
de janvier donc il peut signer où il
veut c'est bien ça et gratuitement donc
on ne sait jamais peut-être qu'on verra
qu'il y allait maps et attrapes merci
bixente pour toutes ces précisions vous
retrouve la semaine prochaine il y avait
également du handball féminin ce
week-end troisième victoire de la saison
pour l'équipe de montigny le bretonneux
lésiné montrent l ont emporté 25 à 23
face à issy paris dans le championnat de
nationale 2 une victoire qui leur permet
de s'installer dans le haut du
classement des images de ses lilas
richard
les joueuses de montigny le bretonneux
peuvent laisser éclater leur joie elles
viennent de signer leur troisième
victoire de la saison face au club
d'issy paris dans le championnat de
nationale 2 le match a été accroché
jusqu'à la fin 25 à 20 3 pour les
yvelinoises tu perds faire de nous de
l'équipe on a su rien lâcher à aller
jusqu'au bout et décrocher cette
victoire donc énormément contente de
l'équipe je félicite mes joueurs pour
leur mental parce que chaque fois on
deuxième étant ils sortent et surtout
vraiment une grande partie ça montre que
mentalement on est là il reste beaucoup
de travail à faire
trois victoires de suite c'est bien mais
ça continue il faut que ça continue
cette troisième victoire en quatre
matches discuter permet au club de
s'installer aux premières places
actuellement 3e de la poule 3 de l2 dont
il y le bretonneux est bien parti pour
remplir ses objectifs fixés en début de
saison on a un projet aujourd'hui qui
est d'évoluer au delà en fait de ce
qu'on évolue aujourd'hui et je pense que
oui ce serait une déception ne pas y
arriver c'est certain maintenant on est
il faut aussi être clair avec tout ça on
est dans une poule très compliquée ou en
fait vous avez facilement cinq six clubs
qui peuvent prétendre en fait à une
montée prochain match pour les féminines
de montigny-le-bretonneux le 16 octobre
prochain sur le terrain de tôle carantec
une équipe qui compte autant de points
que les yvelinoises dans ce championnat
en rugby du 6 au 10 octobre aura lieu la
troisième édition des rencontres
mondiales de sport entreprise à athènes
le concept des entreprises en voit
certains de leurs employés sportif
concourir dans leur discipline il y en a
à 27 et l'objectif est de démontrer les
effets à bénéfiques du sport
d'entreprise ludovic de manille joueur
de rugby à plaisir a été sélectionné par
son entreprise veolia a pour y aller
reportage
rugbyman le soir commercial le jour
ludovic de manille fait partie des 160
employés sélectionnés par l'entreprise
véolia pour participer aux rencontres
mondiales de sport d'entreprise à
athènes sa discipline le rugby à 7
toutes les entreprises qui veulent
inscrire des sportifs qui sont dans leur
entreprise quel que soit le sport il ya
plein de sports il ya du tir à l'arc du
basket du foot du hand du beach volley
du rugby à 7 on est 160 sportif veolia à
partir à thème ce sportif qui va fêter
ses 45 ans la semaine prochaine à 35
années de rugby derrière lui trois ans
d'ancienneté dans l'entreprise c'est via
filiale de veolia qu'il a sélectionnés
pour participer spécialisé dans le
traitement des huiles de vidange usagers
et la gestion des déchets spéciaux elle
participe à la compétition depuis
plusieurs années c'est veolia qui on
voit tous les quatre en une
délégation sur différents sports puisque
le format des mondiaux c'est un format
jeux olympiques en fait donc j'ai rempli
le formulaire en fait c'est un espèce de
recrutement sur cv en fait donc selon
mon parcours sportif donc j'ai été
contacté pour pour être sélectionné
participer à cette belle aventure au
total huit français et trois anglais
font partie de l'équipe ils ne se sont
jamais rencontrés mais vont tous
représentez l'entreprise dans
l'entreprise on fait partie d'un groupe
d'une équipe ce qui peut ce qui peut
être retranscrit
aujourd'hui chez c'est via fait partie
de partir d'une entreprise on c'est un
travail d'équipé je pense qu'il est très
très serviable très cohésion d'équipé et
je pense que ça c'est une qualité pour
le sport surtout quand on fait un sport
collectif et tout le monde compte sur
lui même si voilà les années passent ces
on reste toujours compétiteurs donc je
vais pas là-bas pour faire le touriste
c'est si on peut ramener quelque chose
ce serait avec grand plaisir la grande
fierté ah bah il n'y a pas le choix faut
qu'ils nous rapportent quelque chose
on passe maintenant notre coup de
projecteur chaque semaine tv à 60,18
vous propose un zoom sur un club sportif
des yvelines aujourd'hui nous avons
posée à nos caméras du côté du stade
jean maréchal de montigny-le-bretonneux
pour aller rencontrer à les cougars ont
regardé
aujourd'hui tv 60,18 vous propose de
découvrir l'un des meilleurs clubs de
france je parle bien sûr des cougars de
montigny le bretonneux
[Musique]
pour connaître l'histoire du club des
cougars de montigny-le-bretonneux je
suis avec josé le directeur technique
alors josé expliqué noah un petit peu
l'histoire de ce club qui est l'un des
plus gros clubs de france ah oui alors
le club de baseball de montigny a été
créé il ya environ 30 ans donc ça fait
30 ans qu'on existe qu'on est ici à
montigny donc dans un stade qui est dans
la ville ce qui est assez rare donc
c'est un club qui est plutôt familiale
on a beaucoup d'équipés jeunes et aussi
beaucoup d'équipés pour les seniors on
essaie de faire jouer tout le monde donc
dans ce club dans la vie de 30 ans de ce
club on a eu vingt deux terrains donc
celui-là qui est le dernier avec le
renouvellement du de la surface il ya
quatre ans et donc c'est un des plus
beaux terrains de france aussi donc on a
vraiment eu la chance d'avoir c'est une
pelouse synthétique c'est tout à fait
une pelouse synthétique qui un pas de
faux rebonds donc vraiment je dirais des
conditions optimales pour jouer au
baseball et du coup dans le dans le dans
la vie du club on a eu beaucoup de
passage en d1 pour l'équipe élite après
une descente en d2 il ya 5 6 ans une
remontée en d1
il ya trois quatre ans avec une coupe
d'europe il ya deux ans donc voilà les
points phares du club dans la vie des
trente ans et du coup combien de
licenciés au total dans ce club alors
actuellement on est à 2 160 licenciés
donc dont une centaine de jeunes qui se
répartissent sur quatre équipes 9 u 12 u
15 et u 18 u et le reste seniors avec du
baseball essentiellement et aussi quand
même une équipe de softball aussi donc
l'objectif c'est quoi finalement c'est
de créer une émulsion sein du club
peut-être pour pour ces jeunes pour
qu'ils arrivent au final dans cette
équipe première oui et c'est tout à fait
ça nous on essaie de mettre en place je
dirais tout des différentes mécaniques
pour que ces jeunes qui s'entraînent
actuellement à y jouer au plus haut
niveau en france et pourquoi pas aussi
percer aux etats unis on a quelques
exemples comme mélissa et d'autres
d'autres qui sont issus de ce club donc
on est très fiers nous de cet esprit
famille mais en même temps de cette
formation qu'on leur donne tout au long
de leur carrière en france oui vous en
avez parlé et mélissa mahieu c'est c'est
un petit peu la star peut être de cette
équipe de ce club mais ça va lui
expliquer nous racontez moi un petit peu
son histoire faisait partie des
potentielles recrues pour intégrer le
baseball chez les garçons oui tout à
fait alors mélissa elle a commencé très
jeune avec son frère comme eux
d'ailleurs villa dans son frère dylan
exactement et ben elle a tout de suite
accroché donc
elle a continué dans le baseball jusqu'à
jouer aussi en équipe fédérale qui était
une équipe qu'il pouvait jouer avec la
d1 à l'époque maintenant elle n'existe
plus et après elle est partie aux états
unis pour jouer au softball donc où elle
fait je dirais une excellente carrière
donc oui c'est une je dirais des
joueuses phare du baseball unis montrent
un français aussi con et vous en servez
peut-être pour pour donner un exemple
peut-être ces jeunes qui sont derrière
là par exemple est ce que tu en avais
parlé déjà avec eux tout à fait alors on
leur donne un exemple c'est ça leur
permet de voir jusqu'où ils peuvent
aller et aussi c'est plutôt un exemple
aussi pour les filles qu'il y avait là
on essaie aussi de féminiser si la
pratique donc voilà on leur dit que
c'est possible c'est pas inaccessible
bien sûr ça demande du travail mais
c'est faisable comment deux filles comme
garçons au total alors alors les filles
sur les équipes jeunes ça représente
entre 10 et 20% l'on sait pas encore
dirait du 50-50 mais on y travaille on a
une équipe filles féminine aussi de
baseball dont deux des joueuses ont
participé à la coupe d'europe il ya deux
ans donc qu'ils sont chez nous donc
voilà c'est c'est un travail qui est à
venir est en progression donc on
travaille régulièrement dessus pour que
voilà les filles viennent s'inscrivent
au baseball est ce que vous sentez que
le club grandit d'année en année est-ce
que vous avez ce sentiment là on l'a eu
chez les jeunes déjà il ya énormément de
monde des partis des gros centres de
formation on peut le dire oui pour pour
le haut niveau est ce que vous sentez
que le club grandit d'année en année oui
alors ça grandit mais voilà on est quand
même limité par la structure parce qu'on
avait seulement un stade et donc du coup
il faut quand même donner du temps
d'entraînement et du temps je dirais
qualitatif à tout le monde donc on aura
des limites qu'on en train d'atteindre
en termes de temps et de qualité donc on
est va essayer aussi de trouver d'autres
solutions pour pouvoir avoir un terrain
annexe pour pouvoir
avoir des entraînements qui se veut
enfin plus d'entraînement mais sur deux
terrains donc c'est quelque chose sur
laquelle on travaille avec la mairie la
municipalité montre qu'ils nous aident
énormément d'ailleurs donc oui ça
grandit
on souhaite que ça grandissent plus vite
mais voilà on a quand même besoin de
moyens et de personnes au ciné pour
encadrer tous ces jeunes alors on a
beaucoup parlé des jeunes on va aller
les voir justement
[Musique]
alors des vies est ce qu'il ya des
pépites dans dance et u12 oui tout à
fait il ya quelques quelques enfants qui
se démarque particulièrement
après ce sont pour la plupart des
enfants qui ont commencé très jeune donc
on a eu un travail qui a été fait depuis
depuis les sections moins de 6 ans moins
de 9 ans et c'est ces enfants-là qui
commence très tôt qui qui se démarque le
plus et comment on fait pour justement
peaufiner leur talent quand ça se passe
alors il ya beaucoup de parents
bénévoles au sein du club qui aident à
entraîner et depuis depuis l'année
dernière le club a engagé un
professionnel pour justement à passer au
niveau supérieur et du coup ces jeunes u
12 est ce que vous trouvez qu'ils
performent de plus en plus au fur et à
mesure des saisons est ce que vous
pensez qu'il ya un réel niveau qui
s'installent ici à mentir retenu à tout
à fait vrai on voit ça pousse les jeunes
les jeunes des sections plus basses
pouces et on voit là on voit le niveau
progressivement au fur et à mesure des
années là on a toute une génération de
qui ont à peu près le même âge et qui
vont qui ont performé cette année et qui
seront encore là l'année prochaine en
u12 et qui risque de faire un bon
résultat si on disait oui parmi les
bonnes performances il ya eu notamment
ces championnats de france et les u12
font partie des meilleures équipes de
france tout simplement expliqué nous un
petit peu voilà on a d'abord l'équipe à
d'abord gagné le championnat régional
donc
on a usé aucune défaite
et ça nous a donné le ticket pour aller
en finale nord on a gagné les finales
nord est donc maintenant on va on est
dans le plateau final deux des quatre
dernières équipes pour essayer de gagner
le titre il ya également un jeune du
club a également qui fait partie de
cette équipe de france tout à fait il y
en a un qui a réussi cette année à ça
faisait longtemps sein du club qui a
réussi à aller en équipe de france et a
joué en coupe d'europe cet été on va les
ajustements à les rencontrer
donc votre coach de vie m'a beaucoup
parlé de vous alors expliquez nous un
petit peu pourquoi vous êtes ici à
montigny-le-bretonneux
parce que
je voulais faire du sport je bats
je suis allé
aux portes ouvertes des sports puis j'ai
découvert ce sport que j'ai voulu faire
l'histoire et vous j'habite pas loin
j'ai commencé ce sport et bah vu
j'aimais bien j'ai continué ça fait
combien de temps et 8 en luttant et du
coup tu es maintenant en équipe de
france c'est toi qui en équipe de france
oui alors expliquez nous un peu cette
aventure de l'équipe de france bah
franchement c'était bien parce que on
aime bien rigoler et puis on s'est bien
amusé et on a surtout eu naguère justice
était bien alors il y en a deux autres
également qu'ils sont et qu'ils sont
performants vous avez fait partie de
l'ile-de-france est ca de l'équipe ile
de france a
participé aux interligues donc c'était
ile-de-france contre toute l'airé toutes
les autres régions de france et on
arrivait troisième sur le championnat
face à une défaite contre auxerre et
nice 6 à 5 et là du coup l'objectif ce
sera forcément de remporter la victoire
et du coup explique expliquez-nous un
peu pourquoi vous avez choisi mon team
route ne alors on l'a vu avec avec
clément il habite juste à côté ce que
c'est le cas aussi pour vous oui et du
coup
j'ai commencé ce sport parce que j'ai
découvert et j'ai essayé c'était bien
mais qu'est ce qui vous plaît dans le
baseball bahamas et l'ambiance qui avec
les joueurs j'aime bien ça j'aime bien
aussi
les stresse le en quoi ce qu'il y a et
puis aussi
le et toujours la lueur d'espoir qu'on
peut remonter à la fin comment elle
avait choqué reliques il ya aussi cette
équipe seniors 1 qui performent
énormément ces dernières saisons est ce
que ça vous donne envie peut-être
d'intégrer un jour cette équipe senior
ah oui oui cruellement oui ça donne
envie d'intégrer ces équipes seniors
parce que quand on voit comment ils
jouent ça fait plaisir et puis on arrive
à atteindre ce niveau là l'objectif
c'est de leur ressembler peut-être vous
regardez un petit peu leur match moi
c'est d'être joueur professionnel de
baseball joue au japon moi mon rêve
c'est d'être le meilleur joueur de
france avec montigny-le-bretonneux
merci beaucoup et on va maintenant
revoir l'équipe senior des cougars de
montille rottner
[Musique]
l'équipe senior de baseball des cougars
de montigny le bretonneux est l'une des
meilleures équipes de france pour
vérifier cela il y as avec moi juste
derrière moi des joueurs de cette équipe
seniors à gabriel jeu natale est-ce que
vous pouvez venir
désolé un je vous interromps un petit
peu dans votre votre entraînement alors
gabriel est ce que vous faites vraiment
partie des meilleures équipes de france
oui oui on en équipe pas mal an depuis
2000 18 on enchaîne des bons
championnats je pense que oui on peut
dire ça je matane vous confirmez
carrément top 3 si vous êtes là depuis
quelques années tous les deux est ce que
vous sentez grandir au niveau de
l'équipe senior rescousse antique le
niveau progresse d'année en année est ce
que vous êtes proche tout simplement
d'un premier titre de champion de france
je pense carrément parce qu'après il ya
le noyau qui s'est créé le côté français
sans avoir à dépendre des étrangers on
commence à vraiment avoir le corps qu'il
faut pour gagner à des matchs sans les
étrangers au final moi je suis d'accord
à chaque année on est plus forts ont
faim on était finaliste après on est en
coupe d'europe ça rapporte de
l'expérience aussi pour l'équipe je
pense qu'on est dans le bon chemin on
est dans un club très familial ici
justement est ce que il ya cet équilibre
doit être respecté entre les
internationaux et les joueurs issus du
centre de formation des jeunes la
converj est derrière nous oui oui bien
sûr enfin un club très familial enfin
nous il faut montrer l'exemple du petit
aussi bon mais oui c'est très bien c'est
très bien pour eux je pense aussi parce
qu'après ça se fait naturellement
c'est à dire les étrangers ils savent
qu'ils sont là plutôt pour nous
accompagner il apporte une expérience
autres surtout ils ont tous joué à
dérider au niveau professionnel donc
après c'est aux petits jeunes français à
nous de faire notre place après gabriel
vous vous êtes fait partie de ce
contingent à étranger vous êtes
brésilien qu'est ce que vous apportez
justement à l'effectif bah moi j'apporte
j'étais dans une académie japonaise
enfin j'essaie de rapporter de toute mon
expérience mes entraînements aider les
petits aussi qu aider
les mes copains du la d1 quelles sont
les forces à votre avis de ce club de
cette structure
un comme qu'on nous avait dit c'est un
centre très familial on est tous
ensemble il n'y a pas de des petits
trucs qui qui à chaque fois ça casse une
équipe non c'est un club très familial
on est très tôt amis je pense que c'est
ça c'est ça la force ça reste ça sert on
vend pas de rêve c'est à dire on va te
dire mais tu vas pas jouer tu vas faire
ta place et tu es mérite c'est comme ça
plutôt que d'attirer des gens et de se
dire tu auras ta place tout de suite pas
les faire jouer les fers de fallait de
se voir un petit peu du sport c'est
honnête il ya quelques années de cela
vous étiez en deuxième division en peu
de temps vous êtes arrivé en coupe
d'europe est ce que vous réalisez un
petit peu le parcours cas par cas où ce
club depuis à plusieurs saisons alors ça
c'est la direction s'est clairement il
avait fixé un projet en tête il était en
d2 en d1 a déjà huit années avant ils
sont remontés ils sont dit on va pas
rater le coche on va on va tout mettre
tous les moyens donc ils ont recruté ce
qu'il fallait en terme joueurs ont
tellement entraîneur et tout le monde
tout le monde a joué le jeu s'est
entraîné à fond ce donner les moyens de
gagner des matches puis on est monté
très haut très très vite ça c'est sûr
est ce que vous êtes arrivés ou au
maximum de l'effectif au maximum des
possibilités de l'effectif vous pouvez
encore mieux faire à votre avis gabriel
alors on peut toujours mieux faire oui
enfin mais là on a un qui peut vraiment
pas mal chaque poste c'est bien un bon
joueurs par poste je pense que on fait
on peut toujours faire mieux mais je
pense que quand on est bien on est dans
le bon schéma est ce que le regard a
changé peut-être aussi sur mon team
obtenu quand vous voit arriver peut-être
dans un stade on se dit c'est
montigny-le-bretonneux attention pour
faire attention ce match est important
ouais avance c'est peut-être un match à
qui on va dire même si avec quelques
bons éléments y avait pas une équipe là
aujourd'hui c'est n'importe quel moment
où l'on prenne les deux matches en fait
donc on fait peur ont fait rugir
est-ce que dès à présent on prépare la
saison prochaine aux cougars mantilles
retenus on sait que cette saison vous
allez terminer au mieux 5e est-ce qu'on
prépare déjà la saison prochaine tout
simplement oui bien sûr on à la base en
d'abord vous finir ça bien finir la
saison en beauté quoi parce que on fait
un parcours très bien très bon parcours
après que leurs efforts et son arrivée
de trouver il faut garder ça il faut
continuer ça pour montrer pour prouver
qu'on est capable l'année prochaine et
un titre de champion de france est
possible l'an prochain a carrément c'est
tout ce qu'on cherche c'est tout ce
qu'on souhaite c'est pour sacre au thon
tron se prépare pour ça qu on cherche
dès maintenant les recrutements s'il y
en a qui n'ont pas déjà été fait le
premier était aussi porteur
on va faire notre mieux
[Musique]
c'est la fin de cette émission à bientôt
sur tv 78
[Musique]